today on our show last kosair of two we
make number one in our pants because of
it electric boogaloo all that and so
much more
oh really just that day
mmm welcome to Batman I bet I'm Kevin
Smith Mardon okay so this happened a
couple weeks ago but let's talk about
flash yes first part of welcome to
earth-2
as you know we're big flash fans on the
show and full disclosure for those
unaware yeah I am going up north to
direct an episode of flash March you're
I'm gonna go jump the shark I'm not the
king shark I'm gonna try to [ __ ] I'm
gonna try to do exactly what they do
every week which is make a comic book
come to life every episode plays like an
issue of the flash such a great job but
they recently went to earth to all the
season long they've been having visits
from earth-2 they sent Grodd to earth to
Bruce Garrett from Grilli ass jay
garrick came from earth to king shark
came over from earth - they've had 52
portals or breaches that they've been
closed or Harrison wells from the earth
- which has been really good strong
stuff
his storyline has been really wonderful
so they finally went to earth to the
tail end of the episode right before he
was like we're going to earth - it's
like they're gonna do it
welcome to air - and we've seen it
before we've seen I love those the doing
selfies what are they doing
they we've seen scenes set on earth -
but our characters have never gone over
with you right so this created one of
the funnest episodes they've done ever
but also one of the sweetest most
emotionally [ __ ] rooted and powerful
Kreisberg and Berlanti did the story
somebody else wrote the script but
wonderful team effort because the first
episode of welcome to earth - perfect
television well I like top five best of
the flash and that's saying a lot
because that show is really wonderful
really great the fact that they're earth
two is art deco so the whole thing looks
like Batman the Animated Series yes
which is beautiful
really classy shout out not homage if
you will touch the fact that grant gets
to play the Christopher reversion of
Barry on earth - spectacle will be
bowtie
now did you understand him to be was he
meta in that world or no no because iris
has her magic little like meta finder
and it never got off with that bear and
iris is the cop there is a detective
West it's just iris West and that
actress had a blast
they give her great stuff too so much so
they like [ __ ] make iris a cop I will
buy there and they threw one line into
where he's like boy I wish she'd go back
to the paper she's like those are some I
used to do a cop now and you're totally
like oh my god ho totally watch every
episode of this every little thing they
threw in little like when they went to
the police department the mural was
different it didn't look like the one
that you normally see everyone looking
for they're equals and doppelgangers and
stuff cool little you know [ __ ] earth
to type jokes which is a brand-new
category subcategory of comedy
references like on the phone where you
got to see Jesse Martin singing Oh
detective Joe West is singer and you got
to see Jesse Martin sing dude I got wet
I just watching that Jesse Martin for
like for most kids like he's been a cop
on TV for 20 years on Law & Order and
now flash but J Martin from Broadway I
know right I was telling my son he's
like do you think they had him
lip-synching I'm like let me let me let
me tell you some kid he let me put you
on the phone with Jesse Martin yeah and
he'll tell you whether he lip-sync don't
ever say thank you yeah that's a
song-and-dance man my son yeah he truly
song did and it was really like he's
belted out it's one scene but like he
never really gets his thing on that show
but you could tell he's like I don't
know the whole episode seemed like a
real family affair everybody having a
good time like let's do [ __ ] we don't
normally do let's have fun with him
stuff lets this go we're awesome
sunglasses
let's Cisco be reverb and made himself
and try to pull himself to the dark side
and see powers that he didn't know that
he had yeah so it kind of starts him
like look at him as reverb it starts
Cisco maybe going like oh I could do a
lot more than what I'm doing right now
the foam gag was amazing oh dude it
could broke me on the phone well not
just the mom thing that was holy [ __ ]
but like when you saw the phone and it
said Bruce Diana
wow it's an Eddie so Eddie Thawne was
alive and hearth too and stuff which
makes you go like is he [ __ ]
zooom we don't know because we haven't
seen Eddie yet I know zoo mystery are
still full effect still happening and
they [ __ ] did some crimson [ __ ] too
we're at the spoilers detail obviously
spoilers Bosworth this is a [ __ ] two
week old episode you've seen on if you
care
zoom gets berries puts him in the
[ __ ] prison next to Jesse quick and
there's a dude in an iron mask like his
creepy was that like a Japanese horror
movies just banging on the [ __ ] glass
oh yes [ __ ] it's a battle um but the
high-water mark of the show hands down
mark mentioned before is the foam bit
but Barry's home with irises wife this
cute let her play where she's like
kisses them and yeah there Mary just
take it off your shirt like oh hey it
was so awesome and it wasn't like Jay
got her boobies at like she was wearing
like you know [ __ ] very large bra
it's very revealing I get our deco bra
very Art Deco buff but it was an
adorable seeing where she just gets home
whips her shirt off and he's like good
because he's very high one but she says
oh your mom called yeah
and immediately the strings come in and
you're like oh my god like that's right
his mom would be 11 or 2 and he calls
his mom and has like I was bawling on I
was and I knew it somebody before the
episode play people are like do you
think you [ __ ] cried at the season
finale of season 1 wait until you see
tonight's episode so smart and I have
set up a camera to watch the episode
we're gonna get to see you lose your
[ __ ] in this very episode right here
mark yeah now long episode today kids
it's just episode we get to blow the
flash the second part of welcome to
earth 2 is playing tonight right
I'm just err yeah like we were obviously
we're shooting so we haven't watched it
but we'll be caught up by the time we do
the next episode but yeah we just wanted
to kind of like touch base with this
because it was monumental
the episode was fantastic and just like
watching people get to cut loose it's
always so much fun like watching killer
frost yeah okay they call of the dark
stories dark storms death story that's
what and Robbie Amell comes yak and
plays him and I was repeating they're
making out and [ __ ] but yeah she gets to
that actress with Danielle pen
gets to like play something like poor
Kaitlyn every week is the smart girl who
gets [ __ ] on by [ __ ] life yeah
and in this and earth too she got to
like you know [ __ ] chuda scenery and
stuff and where to make up if I can
throw ice bolts and kill people I love
that DC on TV has their version of what
was basically Star Trek's Mirror
Universe yes we got it's like evil Kirk
evil Spock you got to see like sue Lee
doing fencing and sexy or horror like
that's [ __ ] you I think you nailed
something right here man this show is
made by fans not only of this show but
of the genre and of this thing's they've
gone before historically important shows
you know that [ __ ] paved the way for
show like the flash I'm one of them have
see a Star Trek that is their [ __ ]
mirror universe yeah and it's so much
fun it's so much fun because I mean
grant like you and I in a mirror
universe would pretty much be the exact
same yeah it's yeah what are
doppelgangers like we go ders I do it's
the exact same [ __ ] two dudes put of
a camp just cracking rise above in these
like wait so you guys aren't even
reverse black-and-white on earth to like
no doubt no cess nothing scandalous you
know what on earth - this show is
shorter yes that's it and I'm wearing a
hockey jersey minor differences I'm here
this I'm gonna throw this out there man
um I think zoom is closer to home than
we have been led to believe that is a
very deft threading of a needle my
friend thank you yeah well I mean that's
the thing it's like that's the mystery
of this season who's oom we're getting
closer to finding zoom out and they're
dropping hints mm-hmm
you know it's starting to become
pictures start and become clear yes
while being very muddled because these
cats they know how to keep you on the
edge you see they know how to make you
turn to [ __ ] page in real life you
know and so much so they like alright
I'm watching the next episode
Jesse Martin was great his death scene
had me crying you know him like what he
say goes every song was for you baby
please talking to high-risk oh my god
like that was [ __ ] amazing and
wonderful wonderful [ __ ] to do man
bring it like taking our hearts and just
because it's tough you get to do here
that you'll never get to do or fingers
crossed
will never happen you don't ever want to
see Joe West Diana's good show but we
got to see him die on earth - we get to
see him kill a death scene yeah just so
great know somebody gets to go back to
work next week yeah I'm back no singing
what do you mean Barry like potatoes of
it all but for this episode he got to
like be everything he got to do
completely got to not like Barry I
thought that was kind of cool I hate you
Barry he's there at his worst throat and
[ __ ] like that
sit Barry sit um the fact that he got
Bruce and Hal and Diana on a speed dial
doesn't mean that like he knows the
Justice League because in that world
Bruce wouldn't be Bruce you know Bruce
is probably a well-adjusted guy he went
to college with right Diana would get an
ambassador and how would just be a
[ __ ] fighter pilot we're getting
closer and closer to hell like I'm
telling you I think if they let them go
another season I bet you they're like
yeah taste whatever I mean he'll be in
Justice League I guess but that's a
year's but a few years off like let him
do it let those those cats particularly
Burrell auntie's big [ __ ] Lantern fan
let him [ __ ] the way that were like
Ryan Reynolds got to make up for [ __ ]
in Green Lantern let Greg and he didn't
do it but let him you know you know that
dude is like [ __ ] you I want it like I
want to show you my green lantern to be
filled Martin Campbell's Green Lantern
my Green Lantern Greg Berlanti co-wrote
that Grima I know but I'm saying like a
when you read the stories he's like that
wasn't mine right like there's elements
of my script in there but like when they
moved forward they left us behind and
the [ __ ] got weird
so this would give him his chance to be
like here like you know Greg Berlanti
probably wouldn't have chosen the
animated costume probably not so just
little touches like that gonna make the
difference you know and I bet you like
if he takes how then Justice League gets
Jon Stewart the Justice League movie yes
did you know there's if I'm Batman
they're doing Jon Stewart in hell like
why would you not do surf and turf why
would you not people if I'm that my
throwing Guy Gardner I'd be like we're
doing Oh [ __ ] like I mean maybe
that's maybe that's what they're
building to Justice League like
they are doing Green Lantern Corps so
maybe they bring Green Lantern Corps
into one of the Justice League movies if
they go out to fight Darkseid which
we've seen like the Omega sign and
Batman trimmin stuff maybe that's how
Green Lantern Corps gets into it totally
steal what they [ __ ] did Nova Corps
was Green Lantern Corps in the guardians
of galaxy right just do what they did I
mean here's the ears the tricky thing I
remember taking my son to see Green
Lantern and at the time he was like
eight and single single he's talking
about his boys sorry about my points it
was he Green Lantern and he was like so
Danny what what makes Green Lantern
special it's like well uh so cuz there's
like 800 other space cops right yeah and
they're all like better at this than he
is right yeah so why do I care about how
Joe go to a 2-shot for the trial is
important this guy is the guy you want
to hire for everything that you're
working on I say that every week but now
I'm gonna say your boys move out the
boys got his head on straight man Sierra
hands up question the wide why should I
care about the worst person at this it's
true and it makes you go well what are
they ever gonna do a Nova movie because
they've done the Nova Corps and Nova is
[ __ ] more of a big Marvel character
but essentially Nova is like a Green
Lantern he's one of the Nova Corps right
so so like that that that problem just
becomes that when you start adding Green
Lantern's on top of Green Lantern's on
the Green Lantern's like then what makes
this guys special especially when you're
like get out of the way Kilowog look you
know about humans Inc awesome this guy
looks like a giant walrus moose cow
thing fighting people that give him a
ring like that's more interesting green
lining to look at then a normal guy yeah
I mean it but if you're gonna do like
this series version Green Lantern where
it's basically a cop show in space a
bunch of other cops in the precinct
that's totally fine wait a second say it
again
a bunch of you're gonna do space cop
show again space cops yes if they do
Green Lantern movie and they use Jon
Stewart and Hal Jordan then you get a
buddy cup
you leave the weapon did you get a throw
up you know lethal weapon in space in DC
right I mean just my problem is always
can we make that movie let us let us
have it
wait I'm hearing that's enough evil down
here we were the know from Burbank
what's that
this doesn't scoot closer yes yeah you
can't have that yeah you guys the [ __ ]
you kidding um don't give it to us give
me the [ __ ] burl ante let's get
everything to Burrell ante right now Tim
Miller and Burt Greg Berlanti ah give
them everything and [ __ ] break it
just split it down the middle and let
them [ __ ] pick a cheese man Ryan
Coogler Tanya I mentioned it before dude
re-watch [ __ ] Creed again it's a
superhero movie where it gets the
costume at the end of the shorts and
[ __ ] just doesn't have a master sup but
that dude is a brilliant choice for
Black Panther based on Creed alone oh if
somebody's just like how are these two
things going together perfectly create a
superhero movie it's a [ __ ] superhero
movies phenomenal dude it's just so like
it's it's a more serious superhero movie
than Chris Nolan stuff you know like you
look at Chris Nolan's Batman like boys
taking a [ __ ] seriously Creed is a
superhero movie comic book movie that
just takes it very [ __ ] seriously
he's got continuities got history it's
got [ __ ] deep bench characters they
could pull from and stab or punching
somebody at the end it's fighting with
costumes yep while people look on and a
theme song yes gotta be a winner gotta
be a loser yeah baby um all right so
flash welcome to earth part one which is
like three weeks old me like what the
[ __ ] again we just didn't want to miss
the opportunity to suck this shows [ __ ]
a dick man because it's good when people
do good things this is the Internet and
I know it's like everybody feels their
[ __ ] job to tell you how bad you suck
at something but when people do good
things you gotta [ __ ] praise a man in
this episode is like one of the goodest
things that's happened thus far in 2016
more good please just like this mom you
won't feel good about life watch a
[ __ ] fat man weep yes I set up a
cameraman with me watch it flash so
we're going to end the episode we'll
little montage of me breaking apart well
I watch the [ __ ] show y'all liked
when I put up the video of me crying to
flesh well here is even [ __ ] more of
its
crazy dude like it's I turn it on I
forget about it
then I just [ __ ] dive in the show and
it's so easy forget about because you're
like the show just transport you
yeah granted I wake up at five in the
morning and watch it like alright it
airs Tuesday night so I wake up 5:00 in
the morning smoke like two joints and
watch the flesh so I'm really emotional
when it's going on
it'll sleepy kind of a most perfect
cocktail for tears my kids like can you
take them to school my god run Barry run
I'm baked in wrecked I love they say so
she's like why do I call it you oh
forget it you gotta praise people when
they do good things and this thing is so
[ __ ] good man and it made me so happy
but it also made me happy tears that's
what you're gonna see here so I don't
want anybody to take this footage be
like well you could seriously take this
suppose you'd be like Kevin Smith cries
over his own career or whatever [ __ ] but
don't mistake this footage for somebody
being like they're ruining flat no this
is the [ __ ] opposite this is like oh
my god I love this more than like my dad
I know he's dead he's been dead ten
years but maybe I like it a little more
there I says this is the best Christmas
present on Christmas morning
happy [ __ ] unwrapping tears and you
ain't kidding you ain't kiddin so let's
let's end this episode of fat man I'm
Batman
watching me watch flash pieces and not
the whole episode I'd be [ __ ] up I'm
like here's an hour watching Network
kurai but you know what in a world where
people watch people take [ __ ] out of
boxes online yep
they watch PewDiePie play video games
dude they might watch me watch the flash
everyone
I think they totally would you know what
I'm saying especially if I could deliver
tears every week but after a while after
like [ __ ] five weeks I'd be like stop
crying you fat piece of [ __ ]
I don't really sad cry harder you ain't
weeping enough I want to see the fat
roll and when you cry hard as they call
me cry oh yes more tears KOCO John
McCain is crying there's this footage
that follows is not safe for work cuz
you'll get made fun of the people like
why are you watching a dude cry on the
internet he'll agon that's where my life
is because reasons reasons in this
junkie
you to watch the [ __ ] flash you're a
dead robot inside it's like absolutely
fog and watch a man moved this is really
weird dude I got to share those so [ __ ]
I'm watching this I'm crying at the
conversation with his mom going oh he's
so [ __ ] beautiful while it happens my
mother called the house and I looked at
the phone as I it'll wait I told my mama
and she's gone like you cry over
someone's fake mother your real mother
cause you can pick up the phone I wasn't
thinking bobbum so I think she what in
the hospital the end of the week I'm a
terrible son Jesus oh my god mom don't
watch this video
not for you only for me so strange ah
there it is folks so we're gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna leave but don't forget right
now
no we're spooling it up yeah [ __ ]
we're gonna say goodbye but then that's
gonna happen and then the credits are
going to happen just to let you know
what the future looks like from the past
but they don't this is why we're not
television they don't do that in
television they're like later on we're
gonna say some things they'll say some
things we'll laugh a little and then
we'll go to a commercial they do they
actually do to beat but coming up next
in the next time if we were late night
show totally that's right guess guess we
thought guess we are a funny bit a late
night show
Saxby I mean right which has no time um
there it is thank god there's no [ __ ]
next we consider suck [ __ ] flash off
yeah yeah yeah here it is folks sucking
it wrong without her just like I'm
laughing at how you [ __ ] do it
I'm lapping it I'm not doing yeah yeah
yeah it is ladies who's gonna sizzle in
a single quick you want to be sick so
I'm showing the move oh my god I'm gonna
give and meme that instant Lois hey mom
you're on Facebook how do you spell
relief got to God
in the lap of luxury missions oh the lap
of luxury less your nickname mark the
lap of luxury even though he is the one
shadow presents a lap of luxury
alright so [ __ ] check it out trying
to flash and then come back next week or
next episode rather and we'll talk about
some things that are not flash related
probably not Batman you know what
Batman's coming so we'll talk about that
we got plenty to talk about tons don't
always will for now flash run Barry run
check out me crying to flash and then go
have a good day one night or whatever
today watch me cried at flash and then
masturbate furiously watch masturbate
watching me cry I do I shoot myself
crying then I watch it back it's so
beautiful
oh can I get it chafe that dick friends
ha ha ha
just like Alfred told younger swaying
after his parents are killed in Crime
Alley to chafe that dick master Bruce
master Bruce he took it way wrong
instead what I got is n BB if only you
just chafed your dick master Bruce is
chief your dick it's slang for a
jerk-off I didn't say [ __ ] coming
back don't dick I know your parents were
killed with Jesus that's real bad man
that's why we don't get to no no no
Alfred I named my cogs crime fight crime
fight it fight it he's tossing bagger a
Batarang look Alfred I'm tossing
marriage Oh master you see too many late
Oh put that down put it back in the back
I failed you so miserably just stop
sliding down your medical there's no
more bad bugs no and we're done
this shit's at an end punchy we hop
watch me cry flash and we'll see you
next week for fat man Batman Kevin Smith
mark barnard and we come back neither
the next episode see same pits on
youtube.com such games back there what's
the crime go go go get a tissue go go go
go not for that
you
I wrote this for my parents and Dante if
I don't come back they trick us Cisco
you're coming back to him please hmm
okay thank you hope you get your
daughter back I'll make sure your son
mm-hmm what's that during the speed
cannon on the three of you will be able
to pass through unharmed Barry need to
make sure you keep your speed up mm-hmm
I got no spit Josh not just quoting
Jocelyne with office really dry right
now do not get distracted by anything
you see along the way what are we gonna
see everything
do it jack
let's go okay
what does it mean as long as this
unstable Barry and Cisco will be trapped
over there
ah
welcome to earth-2
Oh
what just happened how did I get here
who are you how do you look like me Alan
what are you doing Harrison wells
um can I see you for a second
CSI Alan hawse pe between husband and
wife is okay
so weird what's that measurement alert
Abbott thinks that your measurement why
are we gone
Oh hmm I'm just not myself I guess your
mom called
ah
our residents oh well I certainly took
your time calling back yeah I'm sorry
about that thank you so much for the
anniversary tickets to Atlantis your dad
and I have always wanted to go I'm
really glad you liked them okay tsunkat
strange
hey I know maybe I should give the plane
tickets to you and iris nice little
romantic getaway
you took a get started on giving me a
grandchild no I want you to use them I'm
really glad to hear you happy mom I love
you Barry
I love you too okay bye honey
ah it's just good to talk to my mom yeah
where is he
crazy I don't know I can't find him
anywhere
Joe can say he's the best
hey baby mmm hey it's Joseph got all new
pop sweet so we got for the show so
Caitlyn and Ronnie's doppelgangers are
evil
some dope names though this was supposed
okay iris and joining me now iris she is
iris okay she is to me what universe I'm
in they are my family I would think by
now you should get how important family
is
I'm going Wells I have to
every single dad don't like this okay
dad dad
or feel
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder